[Musique]
et sportives aussi sont obligés de jouer
le jeu en portant des maillots plutôt
échancrée le règlement va même jusqu'à
préciser la taille de l'échancrure qui
doit être de moins de 10 cm au niveau
des hanches au niveau technique je pense
qu on vous répondra que c'est pour
éviter
pour éviter on va dire des choses trop
long qui gêne et c'est en réalité sont
pour des raisons d'esthétique
c'est assez compréhensible
éviter d'avoir des joueurs la fédération
internationale pour éviter d'avoir des
choses qui portent des shorts de
dans le monde
je roulais elles sont jeunes et jolies
la préparation physique est intense
presque viril mais les dirigeants du
lyon basket féminin ont décidé d'allier
élégance et performance
oui font passer on s'en passerait bien
moins grande évasion
pour la première fois en europe cette
année un club de basket féminin va jouer
la carte séduction
les filles du lbf porteront des roms
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
serena williams d'ailleurs n'a pas
souhaité s'étendre sur le sujet en
conférence de presse vendredi dernier
elle comprend les arguments de bernard
giudicelli le président de la fédération
française quand il dit qu'il ne faut pas
faire tout et n'importe quoi qu'il y a
des codes vestimentaires à respecter
qu'il ne faut pas aller trop loin dans
l'innovation et la provocation
ce n'était pas l'idée d'ailleurs de
serena williams à roland garros quand
elle s'est présentée avec sa tenue de
2,4 humaine avec cette fameuse
combinaison noire mais derrière ça il y
avait aussi un aspect médical il faut
savoir qu'après la naissance de son
premier enfant serena williams a été
victime d'une embolie pulmonaire
elle est donc extrêmement vigilante
concernant sa santé
et cette tenue moulante de catwoman lui
permettait dit elle une meilleure
circulation sanguine
[Musique]